VIC IGLESIAS: Hi, welcome
to the Anthos deep dive.
This will be part 1
of a 2-part session.
My name is Vic Iglesias.
I'm a product
manager with Google,
and I have with me my colleague.
JOHN MURRAY: I'm John Murray.
I'm also a product
manager at Google.
VIC IGLESIAS: Let's dive in.
First thing you need
to know about Anthos
is that Anthos doesn't
just target one persona
within your organization.
There are many personas
that can benefit
from onboarding onto Anthos
and its technologies,
including the infrastructure
operators, the service
operators, and the developers.
And for those
folks, there's going
to be a lot of
different benefits.
Could be that you're looking
for consistency in the way
that you manage
your infrastructure
and applications.
You might be looking to put
security guardrails in place
to make sure that
your developers have
the autonomy they need.
And we'll walk through
some of these benefits
as we go through the talk.
When we're talking
about Anthos, we really
talk about these
five main components.
And today, we're going to talk
about the bottom three here.
So we'll talk about Anthos
GKE, Anthos Config Management,
and Cloud Logging
and Monitoring.
So these are really targeted at
the infrastructure operators.
And in part one,
we'll focus here.
And you'll see service operators
and developers and how they can
benefit from Anthos in part 2.
So first, let's talk
about Anthos GKE
and why customers
choose GKE in general.
We'll break this
down into four parts.
First, it's really
easy to start.
And this is a lot of the
ways that people get started
with Kubernetes in general.
You've got a really intuitive
console that you can use.
You've got CLIs that provide
the functionality that you
need in order to get up
and running and scale
your services.
And you can do this all in
one click, or in one command,
and really have a lot of the
ongoing management handled
by GKE's SREs.
So with that
simplified management,
what do we really mean?
Well, you get in-built
monitoring for all
your Kubernetes clusters.
Whether they live on-prem
or in other cloud providers,
you can hook those
all in and have
all of the monitoring
and metrics
show up in a single
pane of glass interface
within the Google Cloud console.
So this is super helpful for
wrangling all the clusters
that you might have and
all the workloads that you
have across your organization.
Next, we have features like
release channels, which
help you with the
ongoing maintenance
that you might have with
your Kubernetes clusters.
For example, upgrading.
You might not want to always
upgrade to the latest version,
or you might want to upgrade
to the latest version
because it has a feature
that you're looking for.
And so what we have
in these channels
is the ability to pin
to a stream of releases.
So for example, if you're
looking for always the latest
release, you can pin
to the rapid channel,
and that'll give you the
release of Kubernetes
that we've added most recently.
Some customers want to have more
stable releases that we know
have worked well over time.
And they can pin to the stable
channel, which will give them
a slower upgrade cadence.
For folks that are
somewhere in between,
you can pick our regular
channel and get the updates
as they've been vetted by
folks in the rapid channel,
and then will finally pass
on into the stable channel.
So with features
like that, really,
we're optimizing for
ease of management.
But we also optimize for
different types of workloads,
right?
So if you have machine
learning workloads, or really
intensive data programs that
you're running on your GKE
clusters, you might need
some hardware accelerators
in order to enable those to
run at the highest performance.
So with that, we
have the ability
to attach GPUs, TPUs, and
local SSD to your GKE nodes,
all through the declarative
Kubernetes settings
configuration in a
really simple way,
to optimize those
workloads for you.
Additionally, we
want to make sure
that you can run both
your Linux and Windows
workloads in the same cluster.
So with this, we have support
for Windows Server containers.
And they will just
show up right side
by side in the same
interfaces that I've
shown before, with the same
monitoring and metrics,
all in the same cluster.
So really useful for
those mixed workloads.
As you're thinking about scaling
up the amount of workloads
that you have in your
Kubernetes environment,
you're going to
want to make sure
that your clusters
scale really well
and that your workloads
scale really well.
So one way we've
helped with scaling
your workloads is to implement
cloud native load balancing.
With cloud native
load balancing,
you can avoid a second hub
for your requests coming
from the outside world
through load balancers
and go directly to your pods.
So now, not only is
there one less place
where you can have a
single point of failure
for your workloads,
but also you're
getting to your workloads with
the least latency possible.
Additionally, we
also think about how
you might scale up or scale
out your workloads in GKE.
So for example, you might
use vertical pod autoscaling.
When you have a workload
that can't really
scale horizontally, but
needs to scale vertically,
and you don't really understand
how much CPU or memory
it might use, you
can use vertical pod
autoscaling in order
to watch that workload.
And as it reaches the
limits of what it needs,
if it's available
in the cluster,
they'll automatically get those
resources allocated to it so
that it can keep running
and won't crash or move
to another node.
These are the kinds
of features that
make running workloads in
GKE as simple as possible.
Additionally, if you
don't want to think
about what size your nodes
should be for your GKE
clusters, you can use the
node auto-provisioner,
which will just
provision the right size
nodes for the workloads that
you ask from your API server.
And finally, another way we've
helped with scaling Kubernetes
is to make sure that clusters
scale to large number of nodes.
And recently, we
announced that we
can scale up to 15,000 nodes
with a single GKE cluster.
So all this is to say
that customers choose GKE
because we continue to
innovate on your behalf.
And this is something
that we are constantly
working on, and working
with our top customers
to make sure that
their needs are met
and that those can be
used in the simplest
possible way for other users.
We understand, though,
that not everyone can
run on GCP for various reasons.
So we want to make sure that
you can run Anthos and Anthos
GKE in any place where you
want to run Kubernetes cluster.
So with that, we'll start
talking about Anthos GKE
on-prem.
And really, when you think about
on-prem deployment options,
you might ask yourself,
why do customers need this?
Well, one example might be that
they have a database somewhere
inside of their data
center, and they
want to have that workload
as close to the database as
possible, so if they want to
have that Kubernetes cluster
inside their data center.
Another reason might be
that they have data locality
restrictions, and
they have to have
a cluster in a
particular place, and GCP
doesn't have a region there.
So for these types
of use cases, we
have Anthos GKE
on-prem, which will
allow you to deploy Kubernetes
clusters inside your data
center.
And we'll walk through a high
level architecture of how
Anthos GKE on-prem works.
So first, when you're
trying to get Anthos GKE
on-prem installed, you'll point
your laptop, or a developer
workstation, at a vSphere
API inside your data center.
That vSphere API will
then provision what
we call the Admin Workstation.
And this is a Linux machine that
bundles all of the utilities
and binaries that we
need in order to deploy
the rest of the architecture.
So this is really kind of the
seed node for the rest of what
we'll talk about.
Once you have that admin
workstation stood up,
you're going to deploy
the Admin Cluster.
And the Admin Cluster
is the control plane
that allows you to create
many user clusters.
And those user
clusters are the ones
that we're going to hand over
to the end users of Kubernetes.
This Admin Cluster makes sure
that the right number of nodes
is provisioned, that the
right plugins are installed
into your clusters, that
the right functionality is
available to your end
users, and will make sure
that that stays up to date.
So once you have the Admin
Cluster, that control
plane, up and running, you can
start to create user clusters.
And that is done by creating
a Kubernetes resource
and applying that into
the Admin Cluster.
Once you do that, the
Admin Cluster will
look at the
configuration that you've
asked for, as far as what that
cluster should have in it,
the size it should be, how
many nodes it should have,
and it will go ahead and
provision that user cluster
for you.
And then you can get some
credentials out of there
and hand them back
to your users.
This can create up
to 10 user clusters
per GKE on-prem installation.
And each of those 10 user
clusters can have 100 nodes.
So this really
allows you to scale
to a large number of
Kubernetes clusters
within each data
center footprint,
and then provide those
to various use cases
within your organization.
Once you have those user
clusters and the control
plane up and
running, you'll also
want to include load balancing.
And load balancing gets
traffic into your workloads.
So the types of load balancers
that we have available today
are one in-built load balancer,
which is what we recommend.
This is based on some
Google technology
that we provide
L3 load balancing
on behalf of the clusters.
You could also
bring an F5 Big IP
if that was how
you were doing load
balancing in your organization.
Or you could bring your own
load balancer that was not
fully integrated
by us and configure
that to point at your user
clusters and your admin control
panel.
A lot of flexibility there
to get the right setup
that you need.
On-prem is one of the places
where we think about clusters
being required, but we also
know that you have other clouds
that you've been committed to
and have workloads running in,
so we want to make sure that
you can run Anthos GKE on any
of the other cloud providers.
The next thing we'll talk
about is Anthos GKE on AWS.
There's a lot of benefits
to having Anthos GKE on AWS.
One is you get all
the functionality
that I've talked
about in the earlier
part of the talk, where we're
managing clusters for you.
We're integrating
monitoring to those pieces.
And really, it allows
you to integrate
that functionality into
your existing AWS footprint,
so super useful stuff.
The pattern with
Anthos GKE on AWS
is that you'll have a
jump host, similar to how
we had the user laptop in the
Anthos GKE on-prem example.
And that jump host will have a
binary on it called Anthos GKE.
And that binary will talk to
the EC2 API and provision,
again, an Admin Cluster,
which will act as your control
plane for other clusters that
then you provide to your users.
So once you've provisioned
that Admin Cluster,
you're going to go ahead
and run commands against it
to provision your user clusters.
Again, the same pattern
that we had before.
What we do get as a benefit
by running inside of AWS
is we have an in-built load
balancer in elastic load
balancing, ELB.
That comes out of the box.
So you don't have to configure
or run your own load balancer
in that case.
As far as features that are
available in Athos GKE on AWS,
you have the ability
to have HA Control
Planes, auto-scaling, in-place
upgrades, and your storage
backed by AWS's EBS.
If you don't have an
existing VPC in one
and just kick the tires, you can
absolutely create your own VPC
through the Anthos
GKE on AWS installer,
or you can choose to install
into an existing VPC.
And all of these clusters
that you bring up
are going to be well integrated
with Anthos Config Management,
Anthos Service
Management, and Cloud Run
on Anthos, which we'll talk
about in part 2 of this talk.
So now that we have
clusters all over the place,
how are we going to manage
all the workloads across them?
How are we going to
make sure that they
are as uniform as possible,
that we know what's running?
Well, we're going to have
some challenges there.
And Anthos is willing
to help you here.
So we know that users have a
lot of different multi-cluster
use-cases.
We talked about some
around data locality,
being near to databases.
You also might want to have
highly available services.
You might have
different environments
that have different clusters.
And you might have, for
example, a low-latency service
that you want to
have with clusters
that are in different regions.
So the first thing that
you might want to do,
if you're already
a Kubernetes user,
is attach a cluster to
Anthos that you've already
provisioned somewhere
through some other mechanism.
And we allow that.
So you can bring your
own clusters to Anthos,
no matter how they
were provisioned, as
long as they're compliant
of Kubernetes clusters.
So the way that
you do that is you
would register them through
the Google Cloud console,
or via the CLI.
And that would attach them
to our Anthos control plane.
The way that that
actually works is
that we have a agent that
runs inside of your cluster,
and that calls out
of your cluster
and connects to our control
plane in a secure manner.
It actually encrypts
that connection
that's egressing
your environment
and makes sure that it's secure.
And then with that
connection nailed up,
we can start to do
higher order things,
like provide load
bouncing across clusters,
or just show you your
workloads running
for those clusters inside
of the Google Cloud console.
Another thing that you get out
of attaching these clusters
is you get to start
turning on and off features
that you might want
to have using Anthos.
So for example, you might
want to turn on Anthos Config
Management, which we'll
talk about in the last half
of this talk.
You might want to set up load
balancing across the clusters.
And you can do all of that
through the Anthos UI.
Once they're attached,
they're going
to show up just like any
other GKE on GCP cluster.
So you'll have
those listed here.
You'll be able to see which
ones should be upgraded,
what the capacity of
those clusters is,
and whether they're healthy.
So super useful stuff.
So we can talk about
multi-cluster ingress.
Multi-cluster ingress allows us
to have a single load balancer
IP that can point
to multiple clusters
within our Anthos deployment.
So now I can route people
based on the lowest latency
cluster that would reach them.
And if I have a
failover scenario,
I can route to an
additional cluster that
may be in a different region
or a different zone or maybe
in a data center.
So with these
features, we're really
trying to make sure that
Anthos has the ability
to bring to you higher
complex use cases in a really
simple way that maps to how
we do things in the Kubernetes
world.
And with that, we're
going to go ahead and take
a look at how these
things fit together
through the cloud console.
And we're going
to look at how we
manage our clusters from
GKE on GCP, GKE on AWS,
and GKE on-prem.
All right.
Since we now have
seen how Anthos
can get its clusters
provisioned and we've
seen some of the methodologies
for how that's done,
let's take a look
at what we end up
with when we put all of
these things together.
And we'll explore this
using the GCP console.
So here we are on the home page.
I'm going to go ahead and
click on the hamburger
menu over here, and
then down to Anthos.
And the Anthos
dashboard is meant
to tell you your cluster status,
what features you have enabled
on each of those clusters.
We can see here that we
have six clusters currently
in Anthos management.
And we'll see here that some of
them are provided by vSphere.
So this is our GKE
on-prem cluster.
We also have some in
US central within GCP,
US eastern within GCP, then
also one register with Anthos
from AWS.
And you see all these clusters
show up in the same place,
and we can also check
on the current status
of their configurations
to make sure
that they're synced to
the get-ops configuration
that we've put into
our repository.
You can see that all from
the Anthos dashboard here.
If we go into the
Kubernetes dashboard,
we can actually see
some deeper insights
into what's running in our
clusters at this at this time.
So here we have the list
of all of our clusters.
We can see that we have clusters
again in GCP, AWS, and vSphere.
And they all show up in the
same pane of glass here.
We're going to go over
and look at our workloads.
So this can be used as
a UI for Kubernetes.
So here I have a saved
faceted view for My Dope App.
This is an application
that's running
across a bunch of
different clusters.
So we can see here that
I have some running
inside of my
production clusters,
some in my staging clusters,
and some on my dev clusters
on-prem.
So you can see all of these
in a single pane of glass.
And when I click
into these workloads,
I can actually start to see some
of the monitoring and metrics
of how they're operating.
So you can have this
as a developer portal
as well, so they can help debug.
I can also see the events
that might have been fired
for this particular workload.
And I can go ahead and
look at my services that
were provisioned in here.
So a lot of
functionality that can
be found for any
of your clusters
that are registered with Anthos.
The other thing that
you might want to do
is check out your logs
and have an logging view.
So with that we have
the logs view where
you can filter on a bunch
of different things,
including the container
type, the cluster,
or a particular Kubernetes node
if that's giving you trouble.
So if we click on
Kubernetes cluster,
we can see these are the
logs from our clusters
that are registered in GCP.
And we can see all
of the information
about the resources
that have been applied.
We can also go ahead and click
into a particular container
workload and see
the faceted view
of where those are running.
So here we can see the clusters.
I can click on, for example,
my on-prem dev cluster.
And I can see all the logs from
my workloads running there.
I can then filter that down,
for example, by namespace.
So I might click into
the cube system namespace
because something isn't
quite running right.
And I can start to see
all of the information
about things that are
going wrong there.
Next, I wanted to show how I
might add a namespace to all
of my clusters.
Since I have the ability
to manage these clusters
in an uniform way, how might
I add a particular namespace?
All right.
So here we have a
GIT repository that
contains all the
configuration that we want
shared across our clusters.
So for example, if I
wanted to add a namespace,
I could go to the
namespaces folder
and add a file in here that
has some Kubernetes manifest
that I'd want added.
So I'm going to go ahead
and add a new file here.
And I'm going to call it
namespaces/my awesome app.
And in that, I'm going to
create a namespace.yaml.
I'm actually going to
overload this a little bit.
And I'm going to also include
not just the namespace
definition, but actually a pod.
And so we'll see
my namespace get
created, which is going to
be called My Awesome App.
And we're going to
have a pod created,
which is going to be
this web server pod.
So we should see, when we
go back to the console,
that these are all showing
up in our clusters.
So let's go ahead
and commit these.
Now, when you commit
these changes,
they can be reviewed by folks.
You can have a transaction
log of all these changes
that have gone through, just
like any other Git repo.
So let's go take a
look at what this looks
like inside of our console.
So I go back to my Kubernetes
Engine clusters here.
And now I should be able to
see and filter on my namespace
that I just created and
see those pods coming up
with that web server enabled.
So let's see here.
OK.
I see that I have one
of my clusters here.
I go to the
workloads pane, which
is going to contain all the
workloads in all my clusters.
Then I'm going to
go ahead and reset
this one, which was for
my previous application I
was using.
I'm going to look for my new
app called My Awesome App.
Great.
So we can see
here, we've already
got some of these coming up.
So we have a prod-west
cluster that's
running our pod and our
dev on-prem cluster.
So that's it.
We've got things running.
And now we'll hand
it off to John,
who's going to take us
through a little bit more
in detail what ACM, Anthos
Config Management, can provide.
JOHN MURRAY: Thanks, Vic.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about Anthos Config Management.
Anthos Config
Management helps you
manage all of your configuration
and policies at scale
and includes three
different components.
There's Config Sync, for
managing configuration, Policy
Controller, for managing your
governance and compliance
policies, and Config Connector,
for bringing GCP into Anthos.
First, let's talk
about Config Sync
and how it helps you manage
configuration at scale.
So when you've got a large and
diverse hybrid environment that
runs on Kubernetes, you have
a couple of scale problems.
One is scaling your team.
You've got many people
on the operator team who
need to apply configuration
changes to that environment,
whether it's on GCP, on-prem,
or in other public clouds.
And as that team
grows, making changes
against that environment
by running commands
to keep control becomes harder
and harder to keep straight.
You don't know who's doing
what, and you don't necessarily
have a record of things
that have changed.
On the flip side,
all of those clusters
and all of the
different teams sharing
them get bigger and more
diverse in multiple locations,
and it makes it
harder and harder
to roll out changes that
affect the entire environment.
So the way we deal with that
in Anthos Config Management
is through a tool
called Config Sync that
puts all of your configuration
in a centralized policy
repository that's based on Git.
That means everybody
in the operating team
can collaborate together using
methods that they typically
use for application development,
pull requests, and code
reviews.
And that helps your team
work better together.
And then by connecting that
multiplatform environment back
to that central repository,
it helps your environment work
better by having a single,
centralized source of truth
for all of your configuration.
Config Management stores
that configuration and secure
repository and then rolls it out
to all your Kubernetes clusters
and to Anthos Service Mesh.
And that means all
of your configuration
is auditable, that there's a
record of every change that's
made to the environment
stored in that Git repository.
It's revertible, in terms
of being able to roll back
to the last best, good state.
It's transactional in that
changes can be grouped together
and rolled out all at once.
And it's self-healing.
That single source of
truth is kept in sync
with all of your clusters.
And any local changes are
guarded against drift,
so that you can be assured
that it is applied everywhere.
How that looks in a
production environment
might be something like this.
So if you have Google
Cloud platform with a GKE
cluster running on the left and
an on-prem data center that's
running GKE prem
on the right, you
can connect those through
Cloud Interconnect
and have a single
common private network.
The policy repository that
holds all of your configuration
can live on-prem or
it can live in GCP.
In this case, it's
running on-prem.
And that policy
repository allows
you to define your configuration
using abstract namespaces
or inheriting configuration
across multiple teams,
so you can define policies
that apply globally.
In addition to that, you can
specify if configuration should
be rolled out to a single
cluster or a set of clusters
when you need to configure
things differently.
Now let's talk about
managing policies at scale
with Policy Controller.
Policy Controller is included
in Anthos Config Management,
and it is based on the Open
Policy Agent Gatekeeper
project in Opensource.
It allows you to manage
policy at multiple stages
of config deployment, and so
you can inspect configuration
before it gets applied.
You can enforce policies
at the API layer,
inspecting every call that
comes into your Kubernetes
environments.
And then you can run audits
using the same policies
to look at historical
changes, or simply
just to inspect things, without
necessarily enforcing them
actively.
And that means that
any client that
is connected to your clusters
is respecting the guardrails
that you have in place
that enact your security
and compliance policies.
Those policies are
diverse, and that's
why we support custom
policies in Policy Controller.
But Policy Controller also
comes with the default policy
library.
And that includes 27
constraint templates
that are used for
common use cases
that we see all the
time with our customers.
And these are policies that
are maintained by Google
and included as part
of the distribution.
That might be something like
restricting a RoleBinding
to only your corporate domain,
or ensuring that mutual TLS is
turned on so that all
of the traffic running
over your service
mesh is encrypted
in transit at all times.
Finally, let's talk about
managing GCP resources
as part of Anthos.
GCP Config Connector
is designed to expose
all of the popular GCP services
that our customers use as part
of Kubernetes and Anthos.
It does that by taking
every popular GCP API
and turning it into
a Kubernetes API,
so that when you're
deploying applications
through kubectl, through
a git-based deployment
like Config Management
or through API clients,
you can treat GCP as
though it were just
another part of that
Kubernetes environment.
That means you've got a
native API service for GCP.
And you can specify
the resources
that you would like that
underlie your applications,
whether that's a database
or storage bucket
in declarative configuration.
And that configuration will
be continuously reconciled
against the cloud and
guarded against drift.
This is available now,
and it is included as part
of Anthos Configuration.
So all these components can
be installed separately,
but they can all
be used together.
And that means you can store
all of your configuration,
whether it's Kubernetes,
Service Mesh, or GCP
in a single common
Git repository,
roll that out, and
check it for policies
that ensure that it's
compliant with your security
rules and your
operational controls,
and extend that way of managing
configuration from Kubernetes
all the way to GCP.
And that's Anthos
Config Management.
That concludes part
1 of our deep dive.
Stay tuned for
part 2, where we'll
talk about Cloud Run for
Anthos and Anthos Service Mesh.
On behalf of Vic and myself
and all of Google Cloud,
thanks for joining us today.